[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts headmaster albus
dumbledore more specifically we're going
to discuss his fame in a pre-harry
potter era a time when albus dumbledore
wasn't yet supreme mugwump of the
international confederation of wizards
or chief warlock of the wizard gamut i'm
talking pre-1940
that is before dumbledore's famous
defeat of dark wizard gelet grindelwald
as that event undeniably launched
dumbledore into considerable fame
dumbledore touched the lives of many
people during his long long life and by
the time he passed away the staggering
age of 150 his network was immense as
was his celebrated status in the
wizarding world but in the first
fantastic beasts film fantastic beasts
and where to find them we see dumbledore
in quite a different light much younger
devoid of a signature white beard
wearing a totally different outfit than
what we're accustomed to and just
different overall different actor aside
and it's this dumbledore that intrigues
me more than ever this 1926 version of
dumbledore because we know so little
about him and his place in the wizarding
world was this dumbledore famous
starting from the very beginning i want
to break down the timeline of
dumbledore's life looking at it
specifically from the perspective of his
fame or in some cases notoriety let's
jump in 1881 to birth
albus percival wolfrick brian dumbledore
was born in the year 1881 in a town
called mold on the world a mainly
wizarding town in the uk
it was here that albus lived with his
family comprised of his father percival
dumbledore mother kendra dumbledore
sister ariana dumbledore and brother
aberforth dumbledore at this stage
though the family possessed some
powerful wizards the dumbledores were
not particularly famous or noteworthy
1890 to 1891 mughal haters and notoriety
described in his younger years as a
good-looking man with eyes seemed to
twinkle percival dumbledore was a
pureblood wizard husband to kendra and
father to aberforth ariana and albus in
1890 or perhaps 1891 when percival's
daughter and albus's sister ariana was
six she was brutally assaulted by three
muggle boys an incident which left
ariana with an inability to control her
magical abilities when percival first
got the news about what had happened to
his daughter he went and furiously
attacked the three muggle boys in a bout
of rage for this he was sentenced to
azkaban however percival never explained
the reason for attacking the mughals to
the ministry as he feared that if they
knew of her condition she would be
locked away in saints mungo's hospital
due to her existence being a hazard to
the statute of secrecy
this led to much speculation about
percival's crime and many believe that
the attack was driven by a radicalized
perspective on blood purity which
couldn't have been further from the
truth from this point onward the
dumbledore name was tarnished at least
for a time
from rita skeeter's book the life and
lies of albus dumbledore proud and
haughty kendra dumbledore could not bear
to remain in mould on the world after
her husband percival's well-publicized
arrest and imprisonment in azkaban she
therefore decided to uproot the family
and relocate to godric's hollow the
village that was later to gain fame as
the scene of harry potter's strange
escape from you know who like mold on
the wall godric's hollow was home to a
number of wizarding families but as
kendra knew none of them she would be
spared the curiosity about her husband's
crime she'd faced in her former village
1892 first year at hogwarts in the
autumn of 1892 at the age of 11 albus
began attending hogwarts however when he
first started attending the school he
had a bit of a hard time as there was
still a lot of stigma surrounding his
father percival who was sent to azkaban
for attacking the children because of
his father's actions people were under
the impression that the dumbledore
family hated muggles albus included and
this made his formative year at hogwarts
difficult albus at this stage was
certainly not famous and perhaps just a
little infamous for his connection to
his father elfair stoge said the
following about this
for his part albus had arrived at
hogwarts under the burden of unwanted
notoriety scarcely a year previously his
father percival had been convicted of a
savage and well-publicized attack upon
three young mughals 1892-1893
redemption after dumbledore's formative
year at hogwarts where he was viewed in
quite a negative light dumbledore was
able to overcome this negative
perception of himself by excelling in
school and showcasing his generally
positive demeanor in fact dumbledore
quickly showcased what looked like
prodigious magical ability which allowed
him to shine among his peers elfie stoge
discussed this as well in a matter of
months however albus's own fame had
begun to eclipse that of his father by
the end of his first year he would never
again be known as the son of a muggle
hater but as nothing more or less than
the most brilliant student ever seen at
the school 1893-1899
for the remainder of dumbledore studies
with his negative associations now a
thing of the past dumbledore continued
to excel achieving every award in
accolade imaginable in his seventh year
at hogwarts albus took his newts for
both charms and transfiguration newts
are a test that seventh year witches and
wizards take to prepare themselves for
careers after graduation a wizard can
only take the newt exams after
completing all of their owls and
receiving a score of exceeds
expectations
how you do on your newts will dictate
what sort of career path you follow in
the wizarding world albus did
exceptionally well on his newts and
griselda marchbanks a professor working
for the wizarding examinations authority
once remarked that albus was able to do
things with a wand that she had never
seen before albus also went on to win
the barnabas finkley prize for
exceptional spellcasting an award
presented for showcasing excellent
spellcasting techniques he also went on
to win other wizarding accolades such as
a gold medal for the groundbreaking
contributions to the international
alchemical conference at this time albus
was a shining star in the halls of
hogwarts and his fame though not yet
widespread began to grow elfair stoge
said the following about these years in
dumbledore's life he not only won every
prize of note the school offered he was
soon in regular correspondence with the
most notable magical names of the day
including nicolas flamel the celebrated
alchemist matilda bagshot the noted
historian and adelbert waffling the
magical theoretician several of his
papers found their way into learned
publications such as transfiguration
today challenges and charming and the
practical potioneer and rita skeeter had
something to say about it as well in her
book the life and lies of albus
dumbledore now approaching his 18th
birthday dumbledore left hogwarts in a
blaze of glory head boy prefect winner
of the barnabas finkley prize for
exceptional spell casting british youth
representative to the wizard gamut gold
medal winner for groundbreaking
contribution to the international
alchemical conference in cairo
dumbledore intended next to take a grand
tour with elfia's dog breath doge the
dim-witted but devoted sidekick he'd
picked up at school 1899-1900
the year between 1899 and 1900 was a big
one for dumbledore not only was it his
graduation year from hogwarts but it was
also the year that both dumbledore's
mother and sister died as well as the
year that he met and later departed from
gaelit grindelwald though dumbledore had
plans to travel with elfia's doge upon
graduation his plans were thwarted when
he got news that his mother had died in
a tragic accident stemming from his
sister's uncontrolled magical ability
this forced him to return home to take
care of his siblings and briefly stunted
the achievement of a man that could have
done anything this life
dumbledore met grindelwald shortly after
returning to godric's hollow and this
was where the pair had come up with the
grandiose plans surrounding the fabled
deathly hallows however all this came
slamming to a halt when dumbledore's
sister ariana became a casualty in a
three-way jewel involving albus
aberforth and grindelwald at this stage
dumbledore was highly respected and
reasonably well known but famous not yet
1900-1910
the grey years the years following the
death of albus's sister are a little
unclear particularly between the years
1900 and 1910 as we have very little
concrete information that provides us
with dates or details however we do know
that after the death of his sister and
his departure from both grindelwald and
his brother aberforth dumbledore was
free to go about his business as he
pleased however with exact dates aside
we do know that he did a few things one
of the first major events in
dumbledore's life after departing
godric's hollow was his trip to france
where he visited his old friend nicola
flamel flamel was a famed alchemist and
it was in france that dumbledore studied
the ancient art and science of alchemy
under his tutelage
after an unknown period of time
dumbledore returned back to britain and
it just so happened that in this time
period dumbledore became infatuated with
the study of dragon's blood specifically
its uses dumbledore's eventual discovery
and publication the 12 uses of dragon's
blood led to his first taste of real
undeniable fame earning him widespread
recognition and the offer of a teaching
position at hogwarts i know for a fact
that dumbledore was teaching at hogwarts
for the time 1910 rolled around so i
suspect the dumbledore had his first
real taste of fame around 1908 or 1909
1910 to 1926. between 1910 and 1926
dumbledore worked away at hogwarts
vigilantly happy to give back and serve
as a pinnacle of knowledge to the
younger generations of the wizarding
population
during this time period he was even
offered the position for minister of
magic several times an offer that he
would go on to reject each and every
time dumbledore discusses this with
harry later in life
years past there were rumors about
grindelwald they said he had procured a
wand of immense power i meanwhile was
offered the post of minister for magic
not once but several times naturally i
refused i had learned that i was not to
be trusted with power i was safer at
hogwarts i think i was a good teacher
1926-1945
the wizarding conflict i'm not going to
cover these years much because these are
the years covered in the upcoming
fantastic beasts films but i want to
mention a few important things number
one grindelwald's rise to power became
prominent number two the global
wizarding war truly began and at number
three dumbledore became involved in the
war effort when 1945 rolled around
dumbledore decided that he could no
longer turn a blind eye to the
atrocities that grindelwald and his
followers were committing which led to
him tracking him down after finding
grindelwald dumbledore ends up defeating
him in a jewel of epic proportions a
jewel that according to hellfire's doge
no wizarding jewel ever matched
dumbledore's defeat of grindelwald was
the single greatest thing he ever
accomplished in the eyes of the
wizarding community and it cemented him
in history as the most powerful wizard
to have ever lived for his defeat of
grindelwald and effectively ending the
for the greater good revolution
dumbledore was awarded an order of
merlin first class though dumbledore
remained famous for the rest of his days
i would argue that this was perhaps the
height of dumbledore's fame in the
wizarding world and that concludes this
video on the early years of albus
dumbledore and his fame did you learn
something about his past comment what
down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams forget to live
you